it's our new series we're calling it
never too late that's where Nate Vlad
Tony and I get to try something new to
prove that it's never too late to learn
a note and a new skill so yesterday I
learned how to sing and I think you
should say not learned how to sing
singing lessons
there's a difference this morning though
all eyes are on Tony decopal Tony decopo
good morning to you
hey good morning guys I'm sorry to hear
so many people have their flights
delayed but it does put them in a better
position to witness what is sure to be a
milestone moment in the human history of
dance uh I I
had to put on a I had to put on my
coolest jacket this morning I have to
say because uh what you're about to
witness is decidedly not cool when it
comes to dancing I've had a childhood
fear I mean a deep fear it's really more
like a phobia it's not that I didn't go
to dances I went to plenty of them
growing up and I'm not afraid to show
you the pictures here are some of them I
attached the Roses here I am great
haircut buddy looking really cool uh but
when the dance actually started I stuck
to the walls as soon as the music
started and as a grown-up as an adult
this same fear kept me sidelined at
friends weddings and also deprived my
wife Katie of a dance partner time and
time again although she begs sometimes
to get me on the floor I thought none of
this would change ever until it did
sorry Joan Baez the idea of dancing on
camera even with you Joan too much for
me go like this and that's James Brown
not gonna happen Sam Rockwell I think
what's being revealed here is that you
in fact you have a talent for dancing I
know and I do not dj D nice joins us on
the turntables Pier into my eyes America
I am not a dancer see dancing brings out
anxiety
me personally and I think other people
feel uncomfortable too when I start
dancing so you can imagine how I felt
hi Jess
walking into a dance lesson don't you
can't go
session with Jessica Castro so nice to
meet you she's danced with some of the
biggest names in music appeared in hit
movies and taken on some of the other
hard cases in choreography for cbs's
Come Dance With Me I hear that you wanna
dance I don't really want to dance but I
took a quick read of my contract and I
think I kind of have to try to dance do
you trust me
I I you know I'm gonna do my best
[Music]
ball as a way in
I didn't always loved the process
now point to the people no I can't
believe it
yes okay you know what dance is honestly
dance is confidence
this way this way except right seeing
yourself in the mirror looking like this
party starter yes no no yes yes
ends up in the air
[Music]
before long though I did begin to
understand the basics when you feel like
you're getting lost in the sauce yeah
hey just take it in Relax The Groove the
double bounce the step touch right the
Grapevine and The Rock
oh my God Tony this was so good I think
I had fun
[Music]
Jessica asked me to practice some more
at home and I did
but I kept thinking about a day one
problem an issue far bigger than where
to put my feet you hear that beat no
here
the heartbeat I often could not find the
beat come bring your hand here even when
I was literally feeling it feel that
vibration sort of
a problem we would have to address right
away on day two I think the fundamental
challenge for me is not the movement
it's not the grace of it it's not the
pace it's I don't hear music properly
for days right I Hear lyrics and I
follow them I don't hear beat don't get
ahead of the beat as they search for any
sort of Rhythm on that second day it's
like a stamp six seven eight one
I also thought a lot about walking out I
feel like I have a childhood ear injury
but Jessica would not walk out on me you
see the tapping that you're doing with
your feet that's it eventually she got
my attention again with some moves to
help me impress Katie
foreign
that's right there you go
for enthusiasm lifted mine and as our
last Training Day came to a close we're
good
some parting advice instead of looking
down and seeing the dance in your head
come up with it
and just trust
and what we've worked on okay
but come Friday night what I honestly
felt was fear
[Music]
and the hope that something would save
me from embarrassing myself inside this
New York City nightclub we have a couple
more minutes for that blackout come on
New York City turn on your AC's remember
dance is all about what attitude and
confidence that's right
and we have that tonight
yeah yeah we got it
at least Katie was confident I think he
might have a couple moments the guy is a
college baseball player he's very
coordinated he's a graceful man believe
it or not
and once the music started to play I
realized something I probably should
have when I was 17.
foreign
a good night of dancing is not about the
moves it's about the feeling
friends
who in this case dropped by unexpectedly
on a scale of one to ten
and eleven I'm not that I'm a tougher
grader
I agree on you're grading on the curve
clearly
he wasn't trying to be a professional
dancer no he just wanted to have fun
what are you giving I would give him a
nine
nobody's perfect
[Music]
not bad for a former Wallflower
I say Tony you got out there and you did
it and I think that that to me is have
to travel to get out there and have fun
in public with your wife yes that was
amazing there were a couple of times
though Tony I wasn't sure if you were
exercising or dancing
but I think it's fun and there's you
know Ryan in the studio who always has
jokes and said well he was doing the
white man two-step Brian who's White
there are a lot of jokes in studio there
are a lot of jokes in studio but all
kidding aside this is hard to do yeah
publicly when you don't feel comfortable
that's hard
it is hard and and guys I got a whole
list of thank yous here thank you Gail
thank you Vlad for coming out to support
me uh Nate you've supported my journey
through dance as well as a friend giving
me some tips uh also Jessica Castro uh
God has made you a great dancer and
that's what happened a great dance
instructor as well thank you I will
always be grateful my wife will always
be grateful because now I can actually
get on the Dance Floor uh and I have to
say that the the white man two-step it's
a real thing as long as you can do that
you're good as it you documented it is
real no no and I will say this uh Tony I
hope this isn't a Gale King to Human
Resources moment but you got great legs
there you go great legs so at least
you're winning there who wears short
shorts
and we appreciate you well done we're
proud